[Music]
lauren is in atlanta starting off this
hour hi lauren how are you
i'm doing okay how are you doing dave
better than we deserve how can we help
um well i will try to keep this short
my husband and i are currently upside
down in the house that we're in and the
mortgage is in my name and i'm just
desperate to find options besides
bankruptcy but uh wondering if you think
i i should just go ahead and file
bankruptcy
are you behind
no sir um the house how much is your
payment
it is 750
um what do you owe on the house
115 000.
okay and what is what do you think it's
worth
well that's the thing um so back in 2008
um
i put a lot of money in the house
because my grandmother insisted on
staying there
um until she passed that was always what
her goal was and so
the house was very under you know in bad
shape then but just wanted to honor her
so put um had a friend that helped me
kind of put work into the house i was
unaware that the work that was being
done wasn't done properly
um for instance they put a new kitchen
on a rotted subfloor
um
the sills in the house are rotted um
there's wood-eating fungus that's
destroyed
the base of the house
it's just the house is sick we had to
move out about a year and a half ago
for our health we were losing our hair
and
our dog was getting sick as well and
so we've been paying rent and paying the
mortgage um
thinking that we
you know we could just kind of be have
you had anybody look at it to tell you
what it's worth in the crummy condition
that it's in so
it's worthless um
have you had anybody that's a
professional real estate person or
investor look at it and tell you what
it's worth
we've had several people um
and they say it's worth zero
no well forty thousand is what the land
is worth um
so that's what i mean we're upside down
i don't mean to be dramatic it's kind of
well it's not you said it's worthless
that was dramatic it is not worth it's
worth forty thousand bucks okay
so it's
worth anything sir but the land is is
worth 40 000. how much land is involved
5.8 acres where
in atlanta um it's actually outside of
uh outside atlanta uh closest big city i
would say is atlanta um but athens
outside of athens
georgia
so a rural community
yes sir okay
do you have homeowners insurance
i do um and back in 2015 i tried to
contact them to see if they would help
with the mold i had some of the mold
remediated
and it worked temporarily um
but
it's uh
who do you owe the money to
um the mortgage company currently is
regions
is it an fha loan a va loan or a
conventional loan
i believe it is a
conventional but i'm not a hundred
percent okay and what is your household
income
uh my husband and i make around 30 000
currently um okay
you are not bankrupt
but you are in a mess you already knew
that you already knew that okay yes sir
so worst case scenario is
you get foreclosed on
because you quit paying payments on this
today
and um
worst case is
uh okay
the uh
i would go ahead and contact regions
and say i'm done
the house is falling in i can't fix it i
only make thirty thousand dollars a year
put me in touch with your short sale
department
okay get in touch with a real estate
agent at ramseysolutions.com
and interview some of our elps or
endorsed local providers ask them when
you're interviewing them if they have
any experience with a
short sale
okay very few short sales in today's
world but you have a house that has
rotted down and lost its value and
you've got basic structural thing it
just needs a stick of dynamite thrown in
it i hear you it's over yes sir it
wasn't a great house to start with and
then it's gotten worse
and so
here's what's going to happen let's
pretend that 40 000 is a real number i'm
not positive it is
that means this land is worth less than
10 thousand dollars an acre i
suspect you probably get more than that
for it it's in a floodplain i i forgot
to tell you that the whole thing
railroad the railroad expanded well the
d.o.t expanded the highway in front of
the house years ago we have to do that
all five acres is in a flood plain no no
sir okay no
house has been flooding under there for
for many years that's okay the house is
gone
so here's what's gonna happen
the real estate agent gets you an offer
of 40 or 50 000
but you owe
what'd you say 150 115 115 115 then that
offer goes to regions and regions can
decide if they want to accept that
okay and if they accept that offer
then they forgive the rest of the loan
now here's the word you must remember
the phrase you must remember
this is a short sale
without
recourse
without recourse which means they can't
come back after you for the difference
in the 115 and the 50 grand you get for
it
okay but if they get 10 000 bucks an
acre out of this that'd be 50 grand
and they take that offer to regions
region says hey look after we foreclose
on
and we take this property back
we're not going to get 115 for it we're
going to get 50 for it then we've got to
go sue
this woman named lauren who makes 30 000
a year at which point she'll file
chapter 7 bankruptcy and we're going to
get nothing so we're just going to take
this okay that's what a short sale is
that's how the logic works but you've
got to have an agent that knows how to
make that pitch
two regions and work through the
region's
mess
and regions is no picnic to work with
they're a pain in the butt
but maybe
they just are it's a stupid bank so
um
but you know here's the thing
quit paying payments
a
b
number two get a real estate agent
that'll help you with a short sale you
can do that at ramseysolutions.com
and then um c
hopefully we can get them to accept an
offer from an investor or a local guy
who wants to just farm it and push the
house down or whatever right maybe your
next door neighbor wants the property um
and they'll accept it without recourse
okay that way they don't chase you for
the difference kiddo
but this is gonna be a it's gonna take
six months to a year of your life of
screwing with this but all that time
you're gonna be saving 750 bucks a month
because you ain't paying any more
payments
if they do come around and foreclose and
come after you you can deal with it then
settle with them on that